for more on all of it let's bring in CBS
News legal analyst Ricky Clement she
joins us now Ricky good morning everyone
is equal before the law that's the
concept that's the idea but you say you
were surprised that in this case these
charges were brought against Alec
Baldwin and the armor what surprised you
what surprised me were the charges being
brought against Alec Baldwin I was not
surprised that charges were brought
against the armorer it is the armorer's
job to make sure there is no live
ammunition it's the armorer's job to
check the gun Alec Baldwin on the other
hand is functioning in this situation as
an actor he is the last person to get
the gun in the chain we have the armorer
we have the assistant director it gets
to Alec Baldwin the gun winds up in his
hands he believes it is a cold gun it is
called out cold gun so he has no idea or
no reasonable belief that this is in
fact a weapon that would kill someone so
yes I was surprised so Ricky the
district attorney there in Santa Fe says
the key fact is that Alec Baldwin pulled
the trigger that's not an accident she
says that's negligence what will she
have to prove in court to get this
charge to stick
what she has to prove in court is all of
the evidence quality and quantity Beyond
a reasonable doubt that Alec Baldwin was
actually negligent which would give you
a penalty of up to 18 months in jail or
that the negligence was more it was
Reckless it was without due caution and
circumspection and that then jumps it up
to a five-year mandatory minimum what
the prosecutor has said in her interview
is that in fact he she is being looked
at as a defendant in both his role as an
actor and as a producer well as a
producer he might be responsible for all
of the people he hired so you're in a
difficult situation because how do you
defend are you the actor are you the
producer
yeah I mean part of the reason we're
talking about this is because it
involves a celebrity Alec Baldwin will
Celebrity factor into how this case goes
to court or doesn't how it's tried
well it factors in to how it goes to
court and how it is tried both ways
number one is some people may say that
the reason he was charged was because he
was a celebrity so he did not get a
benefit I say one of the reasons he was
charged was because as a celebrity he
made the mistake not only with his
interview with George Stephanopoulos of
saying that he never pulled the trigger
which then you have a battle of experts
who are going to say from the FBI that
the trigger did need to be pulled in
order for the gun to fire versus
Baldwin's experts on the other hand he's
a celebrity and that has persuasive
value before a jury
all right we'll keep following it I know
you will as well Ricky cleeman thank you